son los restos carbonizados de un
incendio provocado en la localidad
francesa de San caiván lepán después de
que le quemaran la casa en marzo y
Enigma es el alcalde del municipio
presentó este jueves su renuncia
He decidido renunciar por motivos
personales particularmente a raíz del
incendio provocado en mi casa y de la
falta de apoyo del estado
una decisión que no sorprende a los
habitantes del pueblo
Supongo de que lo entiendo después de
todo lo que ha pasado quemaron su auto
su casa
lo entiendo pero es vergonzoso que
hayamos llegado a este punto que un
alcalde renuncie por motivos de
seguridad en este pueblo de calma y
tranquilidad donde nunca pasa nada
parece irreal
los planes de la alcaldía de reubicar un
centro de solicitantes de asilo a un
lugar cercano a una escuela primaria han
desencadenado protestas de la extrema
derecha y el alcalde declara haber
recibido varias amenazas de muerte
intentaron intimidarme haciéndome saber
que sabían dónde vivía por ejemplo
dejando mensajes en mi buzón usted
alertó a la policía lo hice y no
hicieron nada nada los diputados se
levantaron y se unieron para ovacionar a
moretz en muestra de apoyo sin embargo
los miembros del partido de extrema
derecha agrupación nacional
permanecieron sentados el presidente
Manuel macron expresó su solidaridad con
el alcalde a través de un mensaje en
Twitter la noticia caldea el ambiente
cuando el gobierno prepara la reforma
migratoria que espera presentar en